[Music]
at 11 o'clock a minute silence
not for Wars gone by
but for a war of our time
it was less remembrance more solidarity
for a country that's faced a year of
brutal aggression
prime minister's past
and present
paid their respects as ukrainians who
now called Britain home prayed for an
end to this conflict
in the city of Bradford we met Olga
forced to leave her family and friends
she's now been living here for eight
months for many like her it's been a
year of pain it was a year of lost it
was a year when you lost your home your
friends your life
and all of us try to find another
another place to live another friends
another people who can support us so
it's one year of our fight
and giving up simply isn't an option for
the Ukrainian Community with a deep
history in Bradford here hope and
strength over the last 12 months has
been needed more than ever
these are Yana's most recent memories of
Ukraine as she fled with her family
bombed buildings on their route out
there's no clearer reminder of War one
half of your mind living in Ukraine
every day she's been here now since
August last year she wants nothing less
than to return home one day you're just
like this you didn't preparate yourself
to all this and when you when you go in
you don't know where to go and you don't
know what what's waiting you next day
and where you will be next day
and how you will survive this day give
them courage and resilience in battle
to make that happen Ukraine needs help
something Britain has been providing
since day one of this war today military
recruits receive training in the
Southeast even on this commemorative day
perhaps a sign there may be more
anniversaries to come into membership
Sky News Bradford